Ron DeSantis causing liberal heads to
explode and all he had to do was show up
in their cities the Florida governor
making stops in blue LED areas of New
York Philadelphia and Chicago and
railing against woke policies there
should not be any of these woke
prosecutors getting elected anywhere in
the country at this point and in Florida
our promise to parents is you send your
kid to school in Florida they're going
to get an education not a political
indoctrination we don't put up with woke
ideology we do not surrender to the woke
mob my state is where woke goes to die
but New York city mayor Eric Adams isn't
a fan claiming DeSantis is the one who
is out of touch
we don't believe in treating people
differently if they're part of the lgbtq
plus Community uh we just don't believe
in the things that he believed in we
don't believe in using uh Asylum Seekers
as props sending them around the country
so there's a philosophical disagreement
and as he came to the city I wanted him
to understand this is a city where we
have a different philosophy and far too
many of the things he believe in and the
liberal media is triggered by the
anti-woke Florida governor
you know it we know it that this whole
war against awokeness is really a war
against freedom and you know what some
conservatives and Libertarians know it
too what's been a problem for Florida is
now a problem for America it isn't just
about the cruise ship companies or
Disney or even your woke gas stove
DeSantis is determined to Stamp Out
intellectual freedom and it's causing
other red states to scrutinize AP black
studies all right Greg I'll call on you
because you reacted to this statement by
Joey Reed that it's a war on freedom it
is a war on freedom if you believe men
should be free to go into women's
bathrooms simply by identifying
themselves as women it you it's a war
against Freedom if you think that
teacher slash activists can talk to your
children about their gender without
telling their parents if you believe
that's an impingement on freedom then it
is a war on freedom it's actually a war
against idiots what we're seeing now is
wokeness is on the on the ropes because
it's not though it's not the right
anymore that's pissed off the left the
center they're all finding it to be an
embarrassment and a common enemy you
cannot defend wokeness without like
feeling like you got something dirty on
you you know because it's so ridiculous
and when you look at the people that are
very woke whether it's on Tick Tock or
whatever they're indistinguishable from
the antifa mug shots they don't look
well like the really woke people they're
poorly capped they're bug eyed they're
tragic looking they look like they need
help and I think that's where woke is is
is at DeSantis realizes that confronting
woke is free money he knows that if you
select the most infuriating element that
is factual then you call it out then the
person finds that it's indefensible and
then they just shut up that's free money
all right don't these stems Joey
understand that we use the facts against
them just as Greg was saying I mean
there are certain truths that can't be
denied
yeah you know so on police especially
this the fund the police it wasn't some
kind of like movement towards a bill
that would take money away from it was a
cultural narrative that said policing is
so rotten in and of itself that it needs
to be done away with and replaced with
Good Will and understanding and
empathetic DA's that won't lock someone
away for breaking a law that maybe was
rooted in what they call racism to begin
with the word racism is almost extinct
now because we can't discern true racism
from wokeness wokeness is racism in and
of itself so the two words themselves
equal out I guess but to go back on
mayor Adams attacking Ron DeSantis he
talks about New York City values I kind
of looked at that tweet and thought from
this okay well they here in New York
City they ban people that aren't vaxxed
they send immigrants to Canada from a
city of seven million calling itself
Sanctuary they send a few thousand
immigrants to Canada because they can't
take it oh and then they stand between
Americans and their right to
self-defense called the Second Amendment
so it seems to me that the values of New
York City politicians are those illusion
oppression and what's the oh yeah
authoritarian and you know Dana one of
the things that Eric Adams talked about
with DeSantis was that he was using the
Asylum Seekers as props and yet uh Eric
Adams was ready to send them all to
Canada I mean yeah unfortunately it was
so cold they came back that's what
happened
um we had a guest on America's Newsroom
this morning Paul Morrow who I think we
all know yeah you know him well and he
had a good point he said that when
DeSantis goes to these cities somebody
like mayor Adams gets allured into into
a debate with him that they're going to
lose and so that it's a pretty smart
move plus DeSantis could probably point
to many officers who have left New York
Philly and Chicago to go to Florida
where they get better pay and they
they'll get the backup that they need in
order to do the job that they want to do
um I I think on the New Yorkers would
love
for a little bit of that DeSantis
attitude and muscle to help them here in
the city especially on the migrant front
we had a story this morning that Madison
Alworth did where you have local
business owners that are near the hotels
where the migrants are being housed and
they've lost foot traffic they are
basically unable to pay their rent and
you know how expensive rents are for
small businesses in New York City and so
they're going to lose their jobs as well
on in addition their tax dollars are
going to to pay for the migrants who are
here who are ungrateful to be here
anyway right so it's a it's a mess and I
think that uh this visit for DeSantis
was pretty smart like Nikki Haley she
and now she's running for president
um and got a lot of attention for it
DeSantis all he has to do is leave
Florida state lines and he gets a ton of
media attention you know Pierce one of
the things that DeSantis talked about
was how absurd our bail law is in New
York where New York apparently is the
only state where you cannot consider the
dangerousness of the uh of the perp
makes sense a lot of what he does and
says makes sense his actions make sense
his rhetoric made sense you know I don't
identify as a conservative although
we're in a world of Limitless
identification so maybe tomorrow I will
um but it's non-binary concerns I'm a
non-binary conservative yeah a brigade
drive me completely nuts and Bill Maher
said interesting thing about this that
it used to be that the sort of right
provided the comic lunacy but now it's
the left and there are a lot of people
like me who are probably slightly left
to send a slightly liberal who look at
these woke people I mean I look at Joy
Reid I think in my worst nightmares
sometimes I wake up in a pool of sweat
and it's because I've been trapped on a
desert island with Joy Reed for the rest
of my natural life and it eats inside my
soul it's like a flesh-eating bug
because when she says the whole war
against wokeness is really a war against
Freedom it's the complete opposite yep
the war is actually from the woke
Brigade against Freedom they want to
tell us all how to think how to eat how
to drink what movies we can like what
statues we can like what presidents we
can say we light every single aspect of
our life they want to control that is
the antithesis of Freedom it's actually
a new form of fascism so when they say
stuff like that you know the Santa is
onto something I would simply say to the
mayor of New York DeSantis was Captain
and star baseball player for the Yale
Bulldogs baseball team he was also the
special counsel to the commander of Seal
Team One in Fallujah I wouldn't pick a
Twitter fight with that guy right that's
what he's doing and I think he's a I
think he's a very impressive operator uh
Ron DeSantis and he's going to take a
lot of stopping
all right I'm going to Brian kill Mead I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now